[MUSIC PLAYING]
WILLEM PIENAAR:
My name is Willem.
I'm the data science
platform lead for Go-Jek.
Today we're going to be talking
about some of the lessons
we learned scaling machine
learning at Go-Jek on Google
Cloud.
So if we're all ready,
I'm going to just dive in.
So who or what is Go-Jek?
So, Go-Jek is an Indonesian
technology startup.
So we have a wide variety
of products and services,
and some of them are on
the screen right now.
The one that we're
most famous for
is our ride-hailing
service, Go-Ride.
And the photo actually shows
you what the service does.
It's a woman being taken
on one of these motorcycles
to a destination.
The reason why it's not a
car and it's a motorcycle
is because of the unique
challenges in Indonesia.
So a lot of people
don't know this,
but Indonesia is one of
the largest countries
in the world by population.
They have over 260
million people.
So it's the fourth
largest country
in the world by population.
And they have a lot
of unique challenges
with public infrastructure
and traffic congestion.
And the way that Indonesians
have solved this problem
is by using motorcycles
to get around.
And they also have their
own motorcycle taxis
called "ojeks."
And when we originally started,
we started as a call center
for ojeks.
So it was offline,
there's no application,
it's completely disconnected.
You just call in
and we sent an ojek
to take you to your destination.
So originally our founders
launched the service.
And there was great
growth and demand for it
because the traffic
is so bad in Indonesia
that the service
really solved work day
problems for Indonesians.
And they continued to collect
information about what products
our customers
wanted in Indonesia.
And in 2015, we launched our
first mobile application.
It was just a modest
bundle of products.
So, the key products there
are Go-Ride, the ride-hailing
on motorcycles;
Go-Food, so that's
food delivery also
in motorcycles;
and then things like Go-Mart--
so it's grocery shopping--
and other logistic services.
And when we launched
this initial application,
the uptake was incredible.
So we hit hyper
growth very quickly.
And the demand in
Indonesia was insatiable
because it solved so many
of the daily problems
that Indonesians had
getting around the city.
And so over the
next couple of years
we launched a bunch of
products, not just at random--
we've always been a very
date-driven company.
We've always looked at what the
customers wanted and launched
very targeted products to them.
So currently we
are a unicorn, one
of the few unicorns in Asia--
or in Southeast Asia.
And we've got 18
products that we've
launched in the application
and many more that
are not in the application.
In 2018 we are focusing on
international expansion.
But let's talk a bit
about our home, Indonesia.
So, our app has been downloaded
almost 80 million times.
We operate in 60 cities
throughout Indonesia.
And in many of our
product verticals,
we're actually the
largest player.
So if I can just talk to
two or three of those.
For ride-hailing, we have
more than a million drivers
on our platform.
On a typical day you'll
have hundreds of thousands
of drivers online at the same
time servicing our customers.
For Go-Food, our food
delivery service,
we have more than 200,000
merchants on our platform.
And we call the merchants
because it's not just
restaurants.
It's also moms and pops
that are selling food
from their garages.
So this platform that
we've built really
allows for a kind of
socioeconomic mobility.
It enables people to
rise up from poverty.
So the third project that I
wanted to highlight is Go-Pay.
It's one of the leading
e-money platforms
that we've launched
in Southeast Asia.
So we have many
different products,
and I just wanted to highlight
the scale at which we're
operating.
So along with that is data.
So this visualization
represents some of the data
points that we're dealing with.
It's a visualization of Jakarta,
the capital city of Indonesia,
where each pixel represents
a person being dropped off
or picked up on our
Go-Ride platform.
So this is just one
type of data point
that we have on
a single product,
but we have many types of
products and data points.
And data science plays a key
role in our organization,
and machine learning as well.
When you have all
these decisions being
made in real time,
machine learning
is critical to making
those decisions.
But the business
and the organization
looks to data science also
to understand our customers.
And especially with
international expansion
looming, we wanted
to understand what
the unique demands
of our customers
were in different markets.
So as a data science
platform lead,
it's my responsibility to make
sure our data scientists are
as efficient as possible so
that their time is being used
correctly and that they have the
right tools available to them.
Especially with
international expansion
you don't want to just
add more data scientists.
You want to really add
leverage to the existing ones
that you have.
So I launched an investigation
into how our data scientists
were spending their
time to see if we
can't improve their efficiency.
And when we launched
this investigation,
one of the data scientists--
on screen, Darius--
came to us and said, hey,
I've got a lot of projects
that I'm working on right now.
I'm actually getting
a bit swamped.
And maybe you can focus
your investigation on me
and see if you can't optimize
the way I'm doing things.
Darius is very representative
of a typical data
scientist in our organization.
He's working on a lot
of interesting things
like fraud detection, driver
allocation, personalization,
and forecasting.
So he's got projects
all across the board.
And we thought that if we could
solve Darius' problems then
we could solve all the
data-scientist-related
inefficiencies.
So we looked at where Darius
was spending his time,
and this is what we found.
So this is a bar of where
Darius is spending his time
on a typical project, so
as part of his lifecycle
of his project.
And we honed in on the different
tasks that he was doing.
The gray areas
represent tasks which
we deem to be not really
data science per se.
So these are tasks like
provisioning infrastructure,
installing software.
Its a systems and
engineering-related work
that Darius was doing.
And then if you look
at the colored blocks,
those are the
data-science-related
that he's an expert at,
that he's good at doing.
So we wanted him to
focus more on that
and less on the engineering.
And if you have a call center
on one day and then a few years
later you have a unicorn--
billion dollar company with
thousands of employees--
and you tell data scientists
to deliver results,
then you get
something like this.
Because data scientists
will need to provision infra
if there's no platform
for them to build on.
They build these
end to end systems.
So what we told Darius
is was that we're
going to try and solve your
inefficiencies and problems
and we're going to look
at all of your projects
through three different lenses.
The first is the
sourcing of data.
The second is
feature engineering.
And the final one will
be machine learning.
And by looking at
these three aspects,
we're going to try and improve
the way you are spending
your time so that you can
focus more on data science
and machine learning.
So the first of the three
is the sourcing of data.
And this is a very
foundational block
that we had to address before we
could get onto machine learning
and feature engineering.
So we asked Darius can you
give us an example of a project
that you were working
on where you had
troubles with sourcing of data.
And this is what he told us.
He says he was working on
an exploratory data analysis
project.
He had this hypothesis that if
a driver is going to pick up
a customer, the closer
they are to the customer,
the quicker it will be
to pick up that customer.
Except, the bit of data that
he had didn't indicate that--
the opposite was actually true.
So, the closer the car is to
the customer, for some drivers,
the longer it takes them
to pick up the driver.
And this was very
counter-intuitive.
So what he said
was, OK, he's going
to investigate why
this is the case.
So what he wanted
to do is he wanted
to look at the specific
drivers in more detail.
So he wanted more
data on the drivers.
So he asked other data
scientists in his team
for this data, and
they didn't have it.
He asked his manager.
He asked the VP
of their science.
He asked the CTO.
Eventually, he was directed to
a team in Bangalore that could
potentially have this data.
And it turns out they
did have the data.
So what they told him was that
he can't query their production
database because
it'll lock the DB
and it will ruin the
driver experience.
And so the problem here
is that this is not really
Darius' job to hunt after data.
So we knew that
this is something
that we needed to address before
we could get to any of the ML
or feature engineering.
So our realization was--
don't go to the data,
let the data come to you.
So the key thing here is
that Darius shouldn't we
have to go after the data.
And we realized we needed
to centralize data storage
within our organization.
And we did it through
the following means.
We said we're going to
build a data foundation.
And we're going to
bring in all the data
from all the product teams
that are being created
on a very frequent basis.
And we're going to do this
with three component--
BigQuery, Kafka,
and Cloud Storage.
So BigQuery will become
our data warehouse.
This is a no-brainer.
I don't know if I have to
sell anybody on BigQuery.
It's big data,
storage, it scales,
it's easy to access SQL.
We needed some of the
functionality in Kafka,
and that's why we opted
for Kafka in this case.
But we do use Pub/Sub as
well, but Kafka's industry
standard event bus, and Cloud
Storage as our data leg.
The problem with this is
that even if you standardize
publishing of data to
a centralized location,
you have to force people either
through a stick or a carrot
to do that.
And we wanted to actually
give them some benefits
or incentives to publish.
So what we said
is, if you publish
your data to this foundation,
we'll give you some benefits.
And the benefits
that we gave them
were reporting, one, so that
their managers were happy.
So we automatically generate
reports based on the data
that you publish there.
We give you automatic archival.
We give you automatic
monitoring and alerting
of your events on Kafka.
And then finally, because you're
using BigQuery and other Google
services like Cloud Storage, you
have centralized authentication
and authorization built in.
So with all these benefits that
we gave all the product teams
and other teams in
the organization,
they started publishing data.
And once they started publishing
data, people like Darius,
and analysts, and other
employees could then find data.
And this led to more insights.
And so what Darius
did is he went back
and he looked at those
drivers, with the weird pattern
of taking very long
to reach customers,
and this is what he found.
So here are two
images that illustrate
what Darius found when he
looked at these drivers.
On the left there's a
driver that's permanently
stationed on a building.
And he's just always
sitting there.
And on the right
there's a driver
that is moving through
a bunch of buildings
at 106 kilometers an hour.
Now in miles per
hour I don't know
what that is-- that's like
60 or 70 miles per hour.
But the point is
that it's impossible.
In Jakarta nobody
moves at that speed.
That's like the speed
of light in Jakarta.
So what we realized is that
these drivers were actually
faking their location.
They were using
software that allowed
them to pretend to be
at a specific location
so that they could get
preferential treatment
by our machine learning models
when they were being assigned
to trips.
So in that case, the
driver was pretending
to be in the shopping mall.
And then if somebody
leaves the shopping mall,
he would be assigned
to that trip.
But in reality, he's
actually far away
And then he would
have to drive there.
So, armed with this
knowledge, Darius
could then go and
build a model that
could identify these drivers
and then react accordingly.
So the key thing
here is building
a data foundation is a
foundational and fundamental
part of solving ML problems.
And you shouldn't be
hiring data scientists--
or at least not many--
until you've built
this fundamental block.
So this was the first
part that we did.
And feature engineering
is the second part.
So we asked Darius
about what projects
he has in feature engineering
where he had frustrations
with working with features.
So he told us about
another project.
And this one is a lot
more important for Go-Jek.
So this is the driver
allocation problem.
So Darius told us
how this works.
So basically if
you're a customer
and you're making a
request for a booking
to go to a destination, you
need to be assigned a driver.
Most customers think
that, OK, they just
want the closest driver
that's right next to them.
Oftentimes you can
see on your little app
there's a driver right
outside your door.
And you wonder why doesn't this
algorithm allocate this driver.
But it's often a
very complex process.
Because sometimes drivers
want to head home.
Sometimes drivers are on a trip.
Sometimes they've just
made a turn onto an highway
and they're going to take
a long time to turn around.
Sometimes you want to optimize
for the driver experience
because they're also
part of our system.
So the drivers
might not have had
an opportunity for a long time
to take a trip with a customer.
So they're also trying
to earn a living.
So basically Darius realized
that the driver allocation
problem is one that is
very dependent on features,
because the features will
really drive the decision-making
of the model.
And this model is
actually extremely
important for our organization.
If you're doing 100 million
bookings every month,
this model is going to
process a lot of money.
And a small tweak to this
model can have a massive impact
on the bottom line.
And so Darius said,
OK, let's first
make a list of all
the features we need.
So he starts listing
down the features.
And these are some of the
typical features that Darius--
off the top of his
head-- came up with.
So there are driver-related
features like what is
the location, speed,
direction, ETA--
so, focused on the
driver features.
And then there's also
customer-related features
like the profile, their
clicks, or their actions,
their history.
Then there are special
features like what's
the demand in this
area, what's the supply
like-- traffic-related features.
And then finally,
temporal features
like what's the time of the
day, what's the day of the week,
is it a public holiday.
Often in Indonesia you
have religious holidays
that can completely change
the way that traffic behaves
and how supply and
demand dynamics change.
So he made this list
of features and then
he set about creating
these features
so that he could train
a model and then deploy
his model into production.
But he ran into some problems.
And these were some of the
problems that he ran into.
So the first problem he ran into
was the volume of feature data.
So we had the data
foundation now.
And what Darius was doing
is he was spinning up
virtual machines and
he was scheduling
jobs that would transform
that information into features
and then publish it somewhere.
And then he would train a
model on those features.
This is a batch process.
It's an offline process,
but it's a scheduled one.
The trick here is that
for data scientists
that's a lot of work.
These pipelines run
for hours and days.
The iteration
cycle is very slow.
And making a small
tweak means you have
to rerun the whole pipeline.
Making a mistake means you
have to start all over.
So this is a frustration
that is costing us
a lot of time,
data science hours,
something we wanted to solve.
The second problem we had
was with real-time features.
So you can imagine if you
have Kafka or an EventStream,
you can't just run
a query on Kafka.
You need to actually
build a system that
streams that data into a data
store with transformations
that builds features.
And then you can access
those features in real time.
So every time we wanted
to launch a project,
we needed an engineer to come
in and build a system that
could stream these
events and build
features for real-time access.
So this is something we wanted
to solve across the board.
The third problem we
had was consistency.
We had engineers now building
features in real time,
and then we had Darius
building it in batch.
But these were disconnected.
The real-time
features were in Java,
and Go, and other
languages like Scala.
And Darius was building
his features in Python.
So there's an
inconsistency there.
And this creates a
problem, because models
are being trained on
one set of features
and they're being
served in production
with different features.
And there's real scope
for problems to come in.
Also, there's
duplication of work.
You actually just want to
define a feature once, or twice.
And then finally, discovery.
So Darius actually went to
lunch with a data scientist
and he realized that this
data scientist had already
developed a lot of the features
that Darius had developed.
And so Darius was
redeveloping the same features
due to a lack of knowledge
and a lack of discovery
in the organization.
So we knew we needed to solve
this problem holistically
for the whole organization so
that the discovery was there
and the standardization
was there.
So our realization was that
features should be free.
You're going to have to pay
a cost to build features
the first time.
But after that, it should
be available in all
of your environments
consistently-- production,
for serving, and for training.
And it should be discoverable.
And you should have information
about your features.
So we were going to build
this platform for Darius
to access features
and create features.
And the first part of
that platform is Dataflow.
So we had our data sources
now with our data foundation,
and we needed a way to solve
the consistency problem.
And how we did that is
by introducing Dataflow.
So what's great about
Dataflow and why
it's so suited for this purpose
is because we want consistency.
We don't want to redefine the
same features over and over.
And with Dataflow,
batch and stream
are supported as
first class citizens.
There's really no
distinction between the two.
They're just different
data sources.
So with Dataflow you can take
in CSVs, you can take in events,
you can take in SQL
relational data,
and then transform it with
a single transformation
and produce it into
any kind of data store.
So by introducing Dataflow,
we have a single place where
Darius can define his feature.
Some of the other
advantages of Dataflow
is that it automatically scales.
There's no servers to manage.
There's no lock-in, because
the code that you write
on Dataflow, the
API is called Beam--
Apache Beam.
It can be run on Flink.
It can be run on Spark.
So there's a portability to the
code you write so you're not
locked into Dataflow.
So some of the
challenges with Dataflow
is that because it's streaming
in batch in all cases,
the API is tricky.
You're also limited by the fact
that Python and Go lang support
is not as featureful as Java.
So in most cases, you'll be
forced to write Java code.
So that's the trick
with Beam and Dataflow.
So often the case
with this is you'll
need an engineer to help define
the features with the data
scientist.
But the key thing here is
once it's defined it's done--
it's always there.
And you can store
your features then
in a training store as
well as a real-time store.
So here's an example of
a feature definition.
So in this case,
we're just going
to look at how
many chips a driver
has completed in the day.
And we take trip events.
This code is Python code.
And then you apply P
transforms on the P collection.
So the trip event
is a collection
of events or elements.
And then you apply
subsequent transformations,
like you filter out all the
successful trips so that you're
only left with that.
You create a data structure
with a count of one per event.
And then you just do a group by.
And then you're left with the
count for all of the drivers.
So this is a very
basic example of how
you could define a feature,
although in our case oftentimes
we use Java to define this.
But it has a lot
more boilerplate.
So now you've solved the feature
creation, and standardization,
and consistency problem.
But now we need to
introduce storage as well.
So for training we
introduced BigQuery.
So BigQuery is just a
no-brainer store for us.
We looked at a lot of
competing databases
to store training
data, but ultimately
it came down to one thing--
our label data is generally in
the data sources as raw data.
And our feature data often needs
to be joined onto our label
data to create training sets.
So we didn't want to have a
completely distinct training
store, or at least not if we
didn't have a good reason.
So we opted for BigQuery
because of its high scalability
and the fact that it's
a completely cloud-based
service-- you don't have to
manage any infrastructure.
Easy to access, SQL-based.
For this use case
it's also very good,
because generally
features are represented
as columns in this data store.
And BigQuery is
a columnar store.
So it's very efficient
at querying feature data.
So that's what we introduced
for our training store.
It's also very closely
integrated with other cloud
services on Google Cloud.
But we'll get to that later.
So for serving we
introduced two data stores.
The first is Bigtable
and the second
is Cloud Memorystore, or
Google's hosted Redis.
Bigtable was really a
game-changer for us,
not just for features but for
other applications as well.
And the reason why
it's so good is
because it allows you to
consistently access feature
data at very low latency--
so, less than 10
milliseconds guaranteed.
It allows you to handle
a very high load.
So you can write and read
to it up to 10,000 times
per second combined per node.
And if you want to scale
up, you just add more nodes.
So you can scale up linearly
to any amount of nodes
with Bigtable.
And then we also introduced
Cloud Memorystore or Redis
for a similar use case.
So sometimes when you
have hundreds of thousands
of drivers there's
so many features,
and some of those
features change
so frequently, that the
load is just incredible.
So you're going to have to
spin up maybe 50 Bigtable nodes
to handle that load.
So let's say you need
to update some features
at a rate of 200,000 or
300,000 times per second.
It doesn't make sense to use
Bigtable for that use case.
So we introduced
Redis, because Redis
allows you to read and write
at an extremely high rate.
Often for these
types of features
we don't care if the
data store goes down.
So, the durability of Redis
is not really a concern for.
Us
And then ultimately we slaped
on top of this whole system
a feature serving API.
This API just
intelligently finds
where the features are located.
So if a feature look-up
request comes in,
it breaks apart that
request, and finds the data,
and joins it back.
And then also very
importantly, there's
also caching in the
feature serving API.
Without that caching,
it's extremely difficult
to handle the load.
But now if you
look at this chart,
you actually have a lot of
information about the features.
You've got Dataflow where
you're creating your features.
You know what features
you've defined.
You've got the
access on the feature
serving API-- like
which features
are being used the most.
And then you've got BigQuery
where you're creating training
data sets and training models.
And you know how
good those models
are performing at inference.
So with all this
data, if you log it,
it's very useful to data
scientists, actually.
And so what we did
is we just dumped
all of that metadata about
features into a database.
And then we just slapped
on top of that Data Studio.
So this is just a
BI tool essentially
that allows you to look at data.
And we can see the
relative efficacy or impact
that specific features
have relative to each other
for predicting
outcomes or optimizing
for specific objectives.
And if you expose this
to data scientists,
then it's a really powerful
tool for some key insights.
And also, even if you didn't
have any of the impact,
if you just had a
list of features,
that's already useful
to data scientists.
Because then they
can take this list
and say, OK, I'm going
to go to BigQuery,
and just select these specific
features, and train my model.
And then finally, this
is what we've built.
So we've got our data sources.
We've got a standard
way in which
Darius can define a feature to
transform those data sources.
He doesn't have to worry
about the training store.
about Memorystore or Bigtable.
He doesn't have to worry
about the serving API.
All he needs to do is find
features in the explorer,
select them in BigQuery,
and train his model,
and then remember
which features are
available in the
feature serving API.
So we've solved his
driver allocation problem
to a large degree because
the feature engineering
was the toughest part for him.
All he needs to do now is define
features as feature transforms.
The final part that we're going
to look at is machine learning.
So we've got both of
the foundational blocks
now of the data sources
and feature engineering.
So let's have a look
at some of the projects
that Darius was looking
at or was working on
for machine learning.
So dynamic pricing is
one of the key things
that all ride-hailing companies
must make or must build.
So the problem
here is that if you
don't have dynamic
pricing, then you have
inefficiencies in your market.
So you have customers
and drivers,
and they need to be matched.
The drivers need to
service your customers.
But if there's not enough
drivers in an area,
you need to incentivize
drivers to move into that area
and service those customers.
And you do this by
having variable pricing
in specific regions.
So here's just an example
of a need map in Jakarta
where the center of
Jakarta has higher prices
than in the outskirts.
And this is just to incentivize
drivers to move into that area
to service those customers.
So when we started with
this model or this project,
Darius said, OK, he's
just going to take
data that's on BigQuery,
train an ML model,
and he's going to deploy it.
And that's what he did--
he trained a model on some
of the data, he had some
ideas, and he deployed it
on the outskirts of one of the
towns as a small experiment.
But there were some problems.
The first problem he
had was it didn't scale.
So his model was
written in Python.
It couldn't scale out of
that experimental base.
The second problem
was with this model
that it was not interpretable.
It was a black box.
And nobody else in
the organization
could explain what it was doing.
And the third problem
was even if we
could look at the
results of the model,
we didn't know if
it was good or bad.
Because this is actually an
extremely challenging problem
to solve.
It's very difficult
to have a baseline
or a control in this
dynamic pricing problem.
If you have an
experiment where you're
raising prices in
one area, you're
affecting essentially
the whole world.
There's no isolation or
apples to apples comparison.
So if you're raising
prices, you're
pulling in supply
from external areas.
And we had other issues as well.
So let's say you've got food
as one of your products-- food
delivery.
And then you've
also got essentially
people delivery on Go-Ride.
They share a supply base.
So if you raise the price
on the Go-Ride side,
then you're taking riders or
people that deliver food away
from your other product.
And this is what
we found, that we
needed to have a very clear
balance between our products
in terms of dynamic pricing.
So this was our realization-- do
machine learning like the great
engineer you are, not like the
great machine learning expert
you aren't.
And this was important for us.
So the reason for
this is that we
knew we were making a
mistake by jumping into ML.
So what we did first is
we defined our objective.
We built a very clear, very
solid engineering system
that could handle
the load and that
could handle a very basic
mathematical model--
not a machine learning model.
And we deployed this
with clear objectives;
with a clear
measurement of success;
with clear dashboards, and
monitoring, and everything;
without any machine learning.
And then we had dynamic pricing.
And now drivers could
see in specific areas
where the prices
were higher or lower.
And then they could
service those areas.
They were incentivized
to go there.
Ultimately, we
would end up adding
machine learning to the system.
But at the start,
the key thing was
knowing what your
success criteria is
and building a rock solid
engineering system first.
But there's still some
inefficiencies in the system.
So what a lot of the
drivers were complaining
to Darius about was that, OK,
you can see that there are
some areas that
are high in demand,
but it's high in
demand for a reason,
it's not high in
demand for no reason.
The fact of the matter is
that there's high traffic,
or there's a bottleneck,
or there's some reason
why it's hard to get there.
So if they had some way to
know in advance that there's
going to be high demand,
that would help them.
And this is where
forecasting came in.
Darius new that
he could actually
forecast what the demand
would be like in those areas.
And so he set about--
or this is what he told us--
building a model that
would do forecasting.
So he would take
all of the data--
all of the supply data,
demand data, traffic data,
user clickstream
data, all the signals
that he could get on
a per-region basis.
So this is an extremely
large amount of data--
terabytes and terabytes of
data that he was streaming in.
This model was so
complex that we even
took both weather
stations in Jakarta
and streamed in weather data.
Because if rain
falls in Jakarta,
then traffic will immediately
change very quickly.
So what he wanted
to do is he wanted
to take all these data
through a TF model
and then predict on a per-region
basis or a per-area basis
what the demand would be.
But he ran into some
challenges as usual.
So one of the
problems he ran into
was that he couldn't
actually train
this model on his local
machine, even as just
a test on a subset of the data.
And when he tried to move the
data onto a virtual machine
and train it there,
it also fell over.
The virtual machine just
couldn't load all of this data
into memory.
So what he did is he asked
a bunch of engineers,
can you help me spin
up a Spark cluster
and train the model there.
So they did that and it worked.
They used Spark, and
they trained the model,
and they could
actually deploy it.
But now there's a
problem because Darius is
dependent on these engineers.
Every time he wants
to make a change,
he needs to ask the
engineers, can you
help me with this cluster.
And another problem he had
was that it was actually
quite slow.
It would take hours--
and sometimes more
than a day-- to
train this model.
So the lesson here was
don't break abstraction--
if you're a data
scientist, try and operate
with the appropriate tooling
at the abstraction layer
that you're comfortable with
and that you're an expert at.
Don't drop down into
the engineering world
unless you absolutely have to.
And as a data science
platform lead,
it's my responsibility
to give Darius
the tools that he needs to
operate at this abstraction
layer.
So what we introduced to
Darius was Cloud ML Engine.
So this is one of
the reasons we also
chose BigQuery as our feature
and world data warehouse.
So it's got a very
close integration
with Cloud ML Engine.
So with Cloud ML
Engine it allows
you to train TensorFlow models.
It's a completely
managed service.
It scales automatically.
Training is distributed.
And there's some
other advantages
like you've got hyper
parameter tuning, which
means your models
can be more accurate.
You've got levers that
you can pull if you want
to iterate and train faster.
You can go from
CPUs, GPus, TPUs.
So this is what we
introduced to Darius.
And the way he used
it was as follows.
He's got his feature
transformations already.
So he's got his Dataflow
creating features
into BigQuery.
Those are the time
series signals
that he is getting
from the field,
like the weather
data that I spoke of.
He trains a model
on Cloud ML Engine
and he serves it
on Cloud ML Engine.
Then his signals are
coming from Kafka as well.
So these are the raw events.
And then he's got a separate
stream that does inference.
So this is just a
Cloud Dataflow job
that triggers serving
on Cloud ML Engine.
So if rain falls, it will
trigger Cloud ML Engine
for new inference,
predict the demand,
and then publish
it back to Kafka.
And so this worked.
One of the downsides to
using Cloud ML Engine
is that it only supports
training for TensorFlow.
So if you want to use XGBoost,
or scikit-learn, or any
of these, it doesn't
work for training.
You can serve those
other types of models.
But there are some downsides.
But for us, the key
thing was we wanted
to have at least one tool
that the data scientists could
use without having
to pull in engineers.
So then we had forecasting.
So these are just three
of the different regions.
So here's a 30-minute forecast.
The green light represents
one of the forecasts
and the yellow line
represents the actual values.
And so we knew what the
demand would be in the future.
We could tell drivers,
this is an area
that will be high in demand.
Or we could just
change the pricing,
and that will also influence
the way the drivers react
to the dynamics.
But this wasn't Darius'
toughest challenge.
Darius had other
challenges as well.
The toughest
challenge Darius had
was on the home screen
of our application.
So this is the home screen.
And you can see at the top
there are some products--
like Go-Ride, and
Go-Car, and those.
But at the bottom, you
can actually scroll down.
There's a very long feed.
And we have full control over
what we display on that feed.
And for us, it's
extremely important
to personalize our application.
All of our customers
use our application
for different reasons.
Some order food,
some buy groceries,
some use it as a
ride-hailing application.
If you have 18 plus products,
you need to customize it.
And as a business,
you have objectives
like you want to introduce new
products to certain customers.
So this is a very important
part of our application.
So Darius was tasked
with building this model.
What his model would get
is the user information--
so, the user's ID,
the user's location,
and the time at which the user
has opened the application.
And then what he
has to respond with
is a list of recommendations to
personalize this home screen.
But this is actually
quite challenging.
Because that data is
only available to us
when the user opens
the application.
So the trick here is that we
don't track users when they're
not inside of our application.
So we don't know
where or when you're
going to open the
application until you do it.
And the type of personalization
we want Darius described it as
follows.
He said that let's say you
know that a person will
order a pizza for his
children on a Friday night.
He's been doing it for
three weeks in a row.
So you want to be able to
recommend buying a pizza to him
if he arrives at home on
that Friday night again.
But if he arrives at
the office, of if he
arrives at a friend's
house, then you
don't want to recommend that.
So that's the type of control
we want in personalization.
So the challenge is,
of course, that we
don't know where or when
the user will pop up.
So Darius said, OK,
fine, he's going to try
and the model to see
if he can serve this.
So here are his
targets on the right.
So he needs to serve a
response in 30 milliseconds.
It's the home screen
of the application,
so you have to serve
responses very quickly.
Our SLO is at 10,000
requests per second.
So the throughput is very high.
And with international
expansion,
we knew we needed to support
even higher throughput soon.
So this model that he
built was an application.
It was embedded
within an application.
And it was before we had
the feature platform.
So in this case, he
actually had user data
that was loaded into the
application statically
as batch data.
So he would get the user ID,
the time, and the Lat/Long
when the user opens
the application.
And then what he would
do is he would transform
based on the user data as
well as the incoming request
new features-- he would
generate new features--
put it into the TensorFlow
model, do inference.
And then it'll produce a
list of recommendations
which he would return.
And so what Darius is
he did a benchmark.
He just had a look
at what performance
he's actually getting
with this application.
And this was his
initial performance.
His target is 30 milliseconds,
but he was serving results
at 140 milliseconds, which is
almost five times too slow.
So, as any engineer
would tell you,
the first thing you do in
Kubernetes is you scale it out.
And that's what we did.
Of course that doesn't
really solve your problem.
There's a certain
amount of complexity
in producing these results
and doing inference.
And scaling up will
just reduce the load.
It won't actually minimize
the latency that much.
So then eventually what we did
is we introduced the feature
platform.
And by doing that,
we could externalize
a lot of the features
outside of this application
so that only the model is
hosted in the application.
And so that's what we did.
But the latency
was still too slow.
It was taking too
long to serve results.
And we couldn't actually deploy
this at scale in production.
It would be too disruptive
to the user experience.
And we really hit a wall here.
And this is a common problem.
Because each project has a
unique model with its own
characteristics, a
completely unique system.
And so we mulled over this
and we came to a realization--
we should pre-compute
everything.
Of course, in this case
it's not that easy to just
pre-compute everything.
Because you don't know
where users will be,
and you don't know when
they'll open the application,
and you don't know
which user it will be.
So the amount of
combinations is immense.
If you have tens of
millions of users,
you need to somehow
reduce the amount
of predictions or
recommendations
that you want to pre-compute.
And the way we did that
is by doing two things.
The first is we bucket
locations into areas.
So we say all the locations
within a football field size
area counts as that area.
And then we bucket time
into windows of, let's say,
30 minutes or an hour.
Then for each customer--
so, for each of our
millions of customers,
and for each of these
tens of thousands
or hundreds of thousands of
areas, and for each of his time
buckets we produce a customized,
personalized recommendation.
But you're still talking
about hundreds or more--
billions-- of recommendations
for a single model.
So this is really, really
big data sets, terabytes
and terabytes of data.
And of course the
solution that we presented
was Bigtable to store this data.
So it's one of the
few tools that we
have found that can
actually store and serve
all of these recommendations.
So the way that we changed
Darius' system was as follows.
So users now have specific
actions that they take.
Let's say that you buy a
pizza on a Friday night.
That is something that
describes your behavior.
We logged that has
an event on Kafka.
And then we have a
Dataflow job that hosts
a model-- a TensorFlow model.
And this model
streams in this event
and then it produces
personalized recommendations
for that user based on the
unique behavior of the user.
And then it stores all
of these recommendations
or it just updates the existing
recommendations in Bigtable.
So this process continually
happens behind the scenes.
And now our model
service has changed.
Now our model service
is a lookup service.
And so the lookup
service, all it's doing
is it's just looking at
Bigtable at a specific landing
zone where that
information is found.
And it just retrieves
it and serves it.
So if you think about
this, this paradigm shift
is very powerful as an engineer.
Because your machine
learning system
is completely disconnected from
the serving infrastructure.
If you delete or
if you remove all
of the ML pipelines
and EventStream,
you still have Bigtable
that's independently testable,
that you know the
characteristics of.
It can handle terabytes of data.
It can serve responses
at 10 milliseconds.
And you'll never
have an issue as long
as you've tested at least
once for your use case.
So this is what we
presented for Darius.
And when we looked
at the performance,
it was good enough--
15 milliseconds.
You're always going to
hit that 15 milliseconds.
There's enough buffer.
Of course this doesn't
solve all of your problems
as an engineer or
a data scientist.
Some models you
can't re-compute.
Some you'll always have to
have a model in a service.
But if you have
the option, think
about storing very
large amounts of data
as an option or an
alternative to serving models
in production because of the
productionizational abilities
of that.
So what are the impacts
of these changes
that we introduced to Darius?
Originally when we looked
at Darius' workflow
on a typical project, he
was spending a lot of time
on provisioning infrastructure,
installing software,
all of these tasks that were
not really data-science-related.
We wanted him to
focus more on what
he's good at, which
is creating features,
developing models, evaluating
experiments, and things.
So we introduced what is
essentially a platform built
on Google Cloud.
And if you look at
the data sources,
we've got all the types
of data sources you want.
Data [INAUDIBLE],,
you've got EventStream,
you've got BigQuery as
your data warehouse.
There's a single place where
Darius can define his features
in Cloud Dataflow.
He doesn't have to define
features anywhere else.
He can do inference in
the stream on Dataflow
by hosting Cloud ML
Models in Dataflow.
Alternatively, he can also
host it on Cloud ML Engine.
He's got a serving
store in Bigtable
and in Cloud Memorystore, and
a training store in BigQuery.
And he doesn't have
to manage those.
Most of this infrastructure
is managed by us.
And it's not really
managed by us as engineers,
because it's all just cloud
services in most of the cases.
So all Darius actually has to
worry about is doing modeling
in Datalab, finding features
in the feature explorer,
and then using BigQuery to
create his training sets,
and using ML Engine
to train those models.
Of course there will
always be custom projects.
I think the key thing here is
that we introduce technologies
that allows Darius to operate
at his abstraction layer
where he doesn't need
to pull in engineers.
He can do things on his own.
And he can produce
results of his own.
He doesn't have to
spin up infrastructure.
So now Darius is using a lot
less time on a typical project.
He's spending more
time developing models.
And because the time has been
compressed, it's faster for him
to get to market and he
can take on more projects.
So the impact on Go-Jek is
our data scientists can now
deliver projects faster.
We have more touchpoints
within our application
because we can
deliver more models.
Our customer experience
has improved a lot
because now the models are
more accurate because we
have more features as well.
We have less data
scientists per customer.
And this is a great
thing, because expanding
to new markets, you
don't necessarily
want to just add
new data scientists.
It is better to leverage
the existing ones you have.
And obviously having
less infrastructure
is a big one for us.
It's less time to spend
managing infrastructure
and it costs less.
And just to recap the lessons.
Let the data come to you.
Centralize your data warehouse.
Don't do anything else unless
you've done that first.
Especially if you have a very
big geographically separated
organization like
we do, for features
you'll pay a cost
once, but then after
that it should be
free and available
in all of your environments,
and discoverable, and trackable.
This is also a very
important step.
And then the third one was
don't break abstraction.
If you're a data
scientist, operate
with the tools at
the abstraction layer
that you're comfortable with,
that you're a domain expert at.
And then finally, if
you have the option,
pre-compute everything.
Pre-compute results.
OK.
That's it for me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]